good morning everybody
it's welcome to the client policy
subcommittee meeting before we go
through the agenda proper the evacuation
urgency evacuation procedure
announcement should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building by the nearest
available exit there is one fire exit in
this room this I think we're all
familiar with which is behind Council
Western if you need to evacuate do so by
the blast or the external virus they
escape staircase please hold both pant
growls in case the stairs are wet or
slippery if anyone is unable to use
stairs would they please allow the
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape door where they can
be given assistance our assembly point
will be in the public car park at the
side of the Civic suite please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings they do not be turned to
building until given permission to do so
by a council staff and I please remind
you to switch off your mobile phones or
turn them to silent thank you very much
okay before we go down the agenda proper
other teasing new faces to the committee
both from from members and from officers
so it might be appropriate we just go
around the table introduce ourselves and
then everybody know that we are on dose
query and turn this planning
Daniel Goodman senior strategic planner
gem guy
Christie Mason thank you very much okay
all right moving on quite another one
apologies for absence we are aware that
council omni's been delayed she's on her
way here but no other apologies of Blues
onion thank you no members attending has
the wall and counts for sure the mix of
meeting held on the 11th of April for
those of us that were here then can we
confirm the diaper
I was counselor hi are you one here
oh well Cass the Western my self-worth
yep and I will sign those at the end of
the meeting to receive any declarations
of interest okay the normal procedure
for the newer members is the will go
obviously go down the agenda as it cited
obviously we've all had the opportunity
to read the paperwork that's been
submitted to us
dan will go through briefly highlighting
any issues that he feels it should be
built out from the paperwork that you've
already read and then we will ask
question or your ability to ask any
questions you want to have officers here
to clarify any points or concerns that
you have when we've done that we'll move
on to the next item so up to you Dan
thanks Jeff and so this item item number
five is proposed updates to the council
adopted statement of community
involvement members might recall that in
October of 2018 council made a decision
to approve two sets well three sets of
amendments for consultation so that
consultation has now taken place
and those amendments are now being
recommended the amendments relates
partly to changes to the sei relating to
neighborhood planning so that basically
clarifies the support that the council
will offer communities looking to
progress through neighborhood planning
and the community involvement at each
stage and that was required by change to
legislation the council was also
recommending that the sei is updated
with respect to how data protection
information is provided so there is an
additional paragraph being recommended
that makes that much clearer the third
addendum as they were as they were
referred to in their previous decision
that related to the South basics plan
has yet to go out to consultation and
that's like a consultation before the
end of this year so at this stage the
count officers are recommending that the
subcommittee recommends to council that
a revised statement community
involvement is adopted incorporating the
changes set out in this paper and no
other aspects of the adopted SCR will
change other than those sets out in
these papers relating to data protection
and they were there planning have
members have many questions and more
than happy to do the same
Thank You mr. chair there are no issue
with the amendments as proposed but I'd
like to ask a question perhaps the
opposite can arise what weight is given
to the comments received from the second
community one who decides for the rating
and so are we referring to the
consultation responses though this may
be yes consultation responses because
there's nothing in there that indicates
the weighting given to information
received so with respect to the specific
consultation on these addendums there is
an appendix which sets out an initial
force a response to those more generally
how that got suppose how the council how
much weight the council gives to
comments received by residents I guess
is a is a case-by-case basis for that
committee or if there's delegated
authority for the officers so I suppose
the statement community involvement
doesn't necessarily clarify exactly how
much weight can be given a I suppose
it's a complex correction that I don't
get I mean the second development
doesn't doesn't it doesn't indicate who
makes that decision in terms of the
consultation on these proposed
amendments officers have looked at the
responses that were received and are
recommending that actually only very
minor adjustments are made to what was
previously recommended largely that's
because a lot of the responses that
received whilst they were you know valid
points valid opinions maybe did not
relate precisely to what was being
proposed therefore there was not a lot
of adjustment needed and there are more
appropriate channels as opposed to pull
some of those other opinions to be to be
considered and appropriate weight given
and that would be through largely
through a new local plank
rotation or a similar consultation on
the actual scope of the planning whereas
obviously this was quite a precise
consultation on very specific yes I
think you're different I didn't read
previously and I was quite happy just
the decision generally can I just
elaborate on that a little bit I mean I
when I read through this and I kept
reading this is outside the reaming of
the consultation which I this is the bit
I was getting that so perhaps then you
could enlighten members as to what route
some of these issues can are being
considered in the in the near future
Chester may be aware yes that's fine so
the comments that related more generally
to how the council plans and planning
outcomes such as house building other
things those will be considered through
the development obviously and new local
plan or other planning documents
obviously will decision will have to be
made at the appropriate time like
officers and members as to how much
weight can be given to resident
individual resident comments the
slightly more precise ones will be
considered by offices and if appropriate
you know actions will be recommended to
this subcommittee but generally speaking
the the recommended route for a lot of
these types of issues to be to be raised
by residents would be through a local
plan consultation where obviously the
scope to incorporate changes is much
greater in this particular circumstance
clearly any comments that didn't relate
to the proposed amendments were not
really ones that that we could take
forward and and we were not consulting
on proposed amendments relating to
anything broader than just neighbors of
planning and data protection in this
case okay anything else
that just VPN absolutely it's quite a
point rule those with these comments
which are outside the remit of this
consultation be automatically put
forward to any new consultation or would
it or would they just be dropped and
that's here in this but reliant upon
them being port forward at the correct
time later but mechanism we can
automatically include the comments I'm
not sure that we could automatically
include the comments but we could prompt
those who made those comments that they
we would it would be ideal if they could
remake those comments should they remain
values with which I would use yes I mean
I mean an informal level clearly we can
take on these comments and see what we
can do but in terms of formally making
these comments I would recommend to
those individuals who made those
comments on this consultation to to
respond to to any future consultation
which may be more of a more appropriate
time for their comments to be what we do
have a recommendation here is proposes
Commission it recommends to council the
Council of Doc's the revised statement
of community involvement set out in
Appendix A and then those the
consultation feedback report sent out in
Appendix B I'll be willing agreement
thank you very much okay on to item C is
the new local plan evidence base housing
delivery test action plan 2019 okay
Daniel again thank you so in this case
changes to national policy so updates
made to the National Planning policy
framework in early 2019 introduced as
what's being referred to as the housing
delivery test the housing delivery test
is a way of measuring the performance of
each authoritative respect to house
building and whether they are building
the required number of homes in their
area and it's it's reported as a percent
and there are various scenarios based on
the authorities performance in terms of
what they then have to do what they then
have to do so any Authority warehouse
building over the previous three years
has fallen below 95% of what they are
required to build he's required to put
together a housing delivery test action
plan and that is what is that that's the
report that this item relates to so in
general that housing livery test action
plan needs to reflect on the causes of
that hunger delivery over the previous
three years and also identify a list of
possible actions that the council and
its offices and and committees need to
take forward to improve housing delivery
over there over there well in the future
so this is going to be an annual
measurement it's a rolling freeway free
year window and there are contained
within this housing delivery test action
plan indications of based on current
projections the councillors future
performance in general the councillors
future performance over the over the
next three to five years is expected to
remain within an acceptable window we're
not much penalty would apply and in some
cases would actually exceed 100% that
that's been required however clearly
beyond the end of that window the the
hasn't every test is likely to indicate
poor performance should the council not
have identified further sources of
housing by then such as Frieda
preparation of a of a new local plan so
the action plan itself discusses many of
the possible reasons why has in livery
over the previous four years has fallen
below expectations partly we think
that's because sites have not come
forward as quickly as we expected them
to do to impart protracted negotiation
between landowners and developers partly
because we as as a council have little
to compel developers to build out at the
rate that we expect therefore we are we
are dependent slightly on the housing
market to determine when when housing
comes forward and there are also other
other kind of issues that are considered
such as land availability so because the
council because the district has quite
constrained land area because of
Greenbelt and flooding and environmental
protected areas there are not a huge
number of sites coming forward therefore
any delays to the delivery of the large
sites
does have a considerable impact on that
housing delivery and in terms of actions
we have identified a number of actions
that can be taken forward including
clearly the development of a new local
plan and other planning documents to
identify new sources of land as well as
things that the council could consider
doing in house such as increase in the
uptake of planning performance
agreements in the development management
function and working more closely with
house builders and developers to try and
encourage faster delivery and from the
perspective of this team there will be
need to to prepare more technical
evidence on land availability through
which improvements the future supply can
hopefully be identified and achieved so
the recommendation for this item is that
the subcommittee note the report and
that it's published on the council's
websites and for the public to view okay
so if you thank you I will report like
this and feel that you know division
objective and then we're marking our own
humbug
we never actually achieved what we set
out in our original objective and I look
at it and sort of think we'll those
reasons and we have to spend on the
environment we're not there but we've
got the real yardstick to compare it
with how other authorities to do and not
try to comfort from a report like this
if we knew in relation to other
authorities how we were doing because
the recent seemed very genuine other
authorities having exactly the same or
we just finding other stuff and they use
the word of courses they bit excuses to
justify why we haven't achieved what we
originally set out to do well I suppose
in terms of local examples I mean there
are several other authorities in Essex
and particularly South Wessex that are
being required to prepare these housing
delivery tests action plans there are
other authorities in the area who have
had not had a local plan or local
development plan in a considerable
period of time and therefore by
comparison actually have poorer housing
livery test performance than than we do
I believe there are something in the
region of a hundred and twenty
authorities nationally that are having
to prepare these action plans and the
consultation the or the engagement that
we gave you some developers through this
did identify that there were some kind
of market level and economic factors
that clearly are not just local over to
Rochefort's such as build costs
accelerating faster than sales prices
which which has an impact on their
viability so by no means are we unique
in having in having these issues and nor
are we unique in having to deliver
housing the retest action plan and truly
unless apart from authorities that
either have very very low housing needs
or have very recently adopted local
plans actually a majority of authorities
are having to prepare these action plans
because the fresh hold of 95% is so high
and typically as an authority there are
very few authorities that the plan for
me you know it's considerably more
housing than they are told they need
therefore any delays whatsoever to to
the housing sites they have identified
almost automatically pushes till eleven
ninety five percent so in a Greenbelt
Authority like ours this this is not
unique but I suppose the hope is that
through the actions we hopefully find
ourselves in a better position than we
are currently yes it does Tara I mean
but these targets are safe for a reason
they're there we have achieved it you
know that's the that's the bottom line
he saying we're also confronting you
know we haven't had a lot of Greenville
but we have achieved it you know it was
the original plan was written in
conjunction with knowing all those
factors so are we're always in this
respect always going to be
underachievement
I think I think is what I think is worth
members bearing in mind but actually
only a few months ago this test didn't
exist so in a sense actually you know
what the government has said is look
here's here's a new measure against
which local authorities should be testy
well actually that's that's what we're
doing but I mean before that there
wasn't there wasn't you know this
hosting delivery test this is a brand
new thing that the government is
actually I'd suggest experimenting with
because I think there's some
there are some issues about the efficacy
of this as a test and whether it is
actually realistic and I know that the
Essex Planning Officers Association
collectively in Essex are doing some
work on this and we'll be submitting
some evidence I think the government
know it's only when I've got offered
I've got a couple of points here that
I'm I want to raise if we're gonna do
this monitoring which obviously seems to
be the case at the moment and we need to
watch it very closely do we have the
resources we now have two of you do we
have enough people to actually do this
monitoring or do we I joined I mean or
should we say that what is going to be
asked of you in light of the timetables
that we're going to have to meet you're
going to talk you're going to be pushed
to achieve this just a simple question
I mean you've got all the other bits and
pieces that you you have to do that are
required to stand up bits and pieces
this monitoring and the other aspects of
it seem to to highlight that there is
gonna be a more more pressure on you to
achieve some of these areas you know you
know maybe appropriate that we highlight
this issue I know Sean done what I want
to hear this but it is a simple reality
that do we have we've got enough
resources to meet what we need to do
that's the long and short of it I think
we might need to to just register this
that it need is an area that needs to be
monitored I mean that I think the
message is received there is a
significant staffing issues generally
yeah taking place so we register that
one in
got a question yeah I think he'll say
which it has got a point I think there's
no point in having a target saying that
we haven't achieved it and monitoring
what we should be doing is addressing
they cause it's a failure okay I've got
a couple points here as well along that
line
do we have concerns I mean you've
highlighted that some of these sites are
being delayed coming on stream because
of despotic disputes between more
developers landowners or is there any
science that we have genuinely concerns
that we will not get them in in this
timescale that we are anticipating
because in the long short of is if their
first delays in them coming online we're
not gonna meet our target next year hmm
what will the year after well in terms
of projections I mean we have it
together want to set our table to really
which is in page six point one six of
the item and which does show that in
housing delivery to tests terms we
expect to actually be by 2023 2024 to be
well over or hasn't literally test
result but then it is I suppose worth
reflecting that hasn't delivery test is
something that looks backwards so it
looks at past performance whereas there
are other things in national policy such
as the requirement to maintain a five
year supply of sites looking forwards
that mean that certain point in time
shouldn't should further sources of land
of housing land not be identified that
you know we may struggle good to like to
demonstrate that we do have that supply
of sites so clearly there are sites in
the plan which are yet to come forward
you know we are I suppose having to
think critically about whether or not
those there are fun
two reasons for that are surmountable or
not and I suppose the council may as a
whole have to make a decision at some
point in time as to whether or not those
sites are deliverable but in in the main
the larger Greenfield housing sites
which are the main sources of houses
supply are clearly all coming forward in
one shape or form
and so the deficit in delivery that
could occur is not likely to occur for
three to four years at which time
possibly we will have a new development
plan in place but obviously this was
worth something worth being aware of and
something worth considering in terms of
you know if those sites would not come
forward you know what impact would that
have should we not be able to you know
adopt a new development plan by that
time should we have I mean we've had
quite an extended period April to
October which seems to be quite an
extensive period since we've had our
last planning policy subcommittee should
we have because of this very issue
having on a more strategic quarterly
basis to review where we're going what
what targets we're meeting and and even
if it's you know solver and our meeting
or half an hour meeting that we are
up-to-date on you can tell us where we
are on you know know everything's online
or no it's not or we have issues but I
think six months seems to be a bit of a
lengthy period between meetings to to
find out what's going on and if there is
a an issue effectively if you tell us up
to six months by the time anything
happens we can be a year down the road
so perhaps we could make it at least of
course Lee yeah yeah I mean yeah I mean
I don't have a I don't have any issue it
meets him more regularly
what do you think then is yeah okay
yes anybody's got any other question
so are we talking about housing do every
targets some time ago there was
discussion on work being done to include
uniform numbers in their clean the
targets now I don't know how far the
council has progressed on that because
obviously that would help our
percentages could you advise how far
that works been done and everything
successful in concluding so in terms of
including a windfall allowance in the
housing in the inner housing trajectory
that's something that when you introduce
a new plan you can make provision
obviously assuming that a certain amount
of housing is going to come forward on
sites that you don't know about yeah so
we did some work that's jest is that the
council was delivering around between 30
and 50 houses a year on sites that
weren't in the development plan so
windfall sites it does it does change
dramatically because obviously a single
site such as board Hall provides more
than that on its own so it does change
dramatically my view is that if we were
looking to publish a trajectory of
housing supply in the future I think we
could robustly justify including
something in the range of 40,000 year in
that but clearly it's more it has more
impact when you adopt a new plan because
obviously if you can justify including
that windfall allowance it means that
you know in theory it might necessitate
less cream not release because you can
demonstrate you're going to meet housing
elsewhere so so yes work has been done
it I suppose it's what that end feeds
into would really take shape I suppose
as part as the development plan review
progresses
included as soon as we can because of
delays on the so if there's any other
way right when I suppose when when the
council produces things like five-year
housing supply position statements so if
developers were looking to to take a
position that the council did not have a
five years of housing supply then I
think the council could could justify
including and allowance in in that in
that trajectory the precise number would
clearly have to be evidenced and because
it because it changes so much
year-on-year it is it is a case of you
know whether you take the mean or or
some other metric but you know my my
view is that we could justify including
something at for something in the order
of 40 a year in in that it's not a mean
average i yes it would be but obviously
it's I suppose if if you had five years
of evidence that showed really high wind
for delivery because sites we know once
in generation sites were coming forward
then you might then struggle to justify
including it beyond once those sites a
bill town even given that the supply of
windfall is relatively consistent from
the urban area you know that I think
that's probably a robust thicker I was
just thinking that the mean average is
probably the best average to use in its
in most areas but hardly that's the
experts thank you for the explain okay
so thank you for picking up on really
your suggestion and reaction now that we
make or break in the Oh
in conjunction with that whether there
could be greater focus on specific sites
and knowing what sites are coming up
yearly so it gets much more micro in
terms of specifics in the report well
you know it's a fairly general report I
think it readable to know what sites are
coming on board on a yearly basis what
we're actually doing there are some
actual figures some power figures to
really crunch quarter by quarter we got
much closer monitoring and stuff that we
can actually identify with when we look
around their own district no that
doesn't make sense I mean we publish
annually well near annually an authority
monitoring report so whilst that doesn't
look backwards that tends to look at
snapshot of housing delivery over the
previous year and try and tries to pick
out any nuances or any new factors that
need to be discussed in that mantra as
to whether we can bring something that's
more quarterly focused to this group I'm
sure we could do that we typically have
not got too involved in the delivery of
small sites purely because there's I
think there's probably little we can
influence but in terms of the strategic
sites you know clearly perhaps there are
there are things that can be discussed
here about the delivery of those sites
and and how they're coming forward
obviously being respectful obviously of
the relationship with the development
committee and decisions that they're
having to make on some of those
strategic sites probably concurrently
that it's not yeah I mean assumption we
came to bring something to give up so
you're not really sure
he's having a much closer hands-on
rather than reactive than just looking
what's happened insane idea is trying to
be reactive but at the same time
proactive in terms of sites that coming
on yeah I think I mean we're all over
someone's aware of issues that are going
on with with other neighboring councils
and we don't want to be included in that
same category so link bill if there's
nothing else
members we have a recommendation it is
proposed that subcommittee resolves with
a housing delivery test action plan 2019
attached to the pending sale be noted as
evidence and published on the council's
website thank you very much okay right
moving on to item number seven the sixth
coastal recreation disturbance avoidance
akiko Dana okay so earlier this year in
April members of this subcommittee did
consider a strategy document that was
been prepared in support of the Essex
coast what I'll call the Essex coast
Rams so to give a brief overview under
the direction of Natural England the
council is one of I believe twelve
councils that have been jointly
developing a strategy which looks at the
impact that new housing growth has on
protected sites along the Essex
coastline and Natural England are of the
view that this strategy is needed to
fulfill each or forties obligations
under the habitat regulations which are
clearly legal obligations that the
council has to comply with in its
planning function so a joint
supplementary planning document has now
been prepared jointly between all those
authorities which seeks to provide all
the relevant information about the Rams
about the process about how it will be
implemented and what
will affect and who it will affect into
an accessible document for mainly for
applicants for planning applications
coal is the the crux of the rams is that
it suggests that 122 pounds of Bertie
will be needed from every new dwelling
on a any sites that have a net increase
in turning numbers to fund mitigation to
fulfill to fulfill the round strategy so
the SPD itself just seeks to explain
that to applicants to explain the
rationale so the legal context and the
process and mechanisms that they can
follow in order to pay that as well as
alternatives to paying that which would
necessitate them undertaking their own
modeling which is likely to be a greater
expense than than what's provided within
for within strategy so the SPD itself
does not include information on the
implementation that's going to need to
be a decision for the council to make
separately about exactly how how the
monies collected are then processed and
used but it does identify the mitigation
that's needed in order to be able to to
mitigate that there the impacts that
recreational disturbance arising from
new housing has so the SPD itself is
recommended to go out to consultation
jointly with all those other local
authorities so it will be a single
consultation that councils will
separately signpost their residents and
obviously any other interested parties
to and it will be undertaken in
compliance with every article every
local authorities poem statement PT
involvement so it will effectively need
to do the maximum of all those local
authorities don't repeat involvements
and subject to the outcomes of that
consultation and
amendments that are required the SPD
would return to this subcommittee
probably early next year with a possible
recommendation that to Council that it
adopts the SPD but clearly at this stage
we are only recommending that it goes
out to consultation and and that we
undertake that consultation jointly with
other local authorities across Essex any
questions then can I just clarify
although it's it's talked about coastal
recreation desert does this apply to all
developments within Rochford district or
already just on there should we say on
the coastal plain but one so so so there
are some what they have called zones of
influence which so the the coastline is
broken up into several different
designated parcels if you like that they
call special protection areas and each
one of those special protection areas
has had a zone of influence drawn around
it so it happens that all over Oxford
district falls within phase and Michael
Moore zones of influence therefore any
new housing development would be
captured by this clearly in the
implementation stage you know the
council will need to consider what the
most pragmatic way of facilitating that
payment is I am of the view that the
payment that the tariff itself is quite
a low value when compared to the cost
building a house and selling a house so
it would seem to be a fair and
proportionate way of fulfilling the
habitat risk in that sense but it would
apply to any new housing development and
with the council will need to undertake
what they call appropriate assessments
at the planning application stage anyway
to fulfill its habitat rigs
obligation
I just wanted to clarify that it's not
just on the coastal plain lis these
whole districts I think those gamers
explain things like extensions you know
changes have used to from a shop to a
tapes way or something like that those
when those wouldn't be captured it's
only residential development and even
any it's only residential development
that has a net increase of stores would
this be captured under a section 106 so
for larger sites it would make sense
that this is incorporated into the
section 106 for smaller sites the
council will need to take a view as to
whether or not that's that's the most
effective way of doing it there is a
form of section 106 called a unilateral
and taking which is in effect usually
one or two sides of paper and it usually
is designed for signal issues like this
so it could be that the council requires
the applicant to submit a unilateral
undertaking alongside their planning
application alternatively it could be
that there's a more pragmatic way of
collecting what is quite a modest
self-giving
that is ultimately a decision for the
council and a decision for its
development management function and
legal functions but it's obviously
something that may that members may be
asked to make a decision on in the
future okay does that clarify the
situation for everyone thank you Ron
we have a recommendation if there's no
more questions they've proposed the
subcommittee records to counsel that the
Essex coast recreational disturbance
avoidance and mitigation strategy
supplementary planning document
breakfast the Rams s ad 2019 attacked at
appendix a be consulted on the period of
the six of six weeks we all agree right
thank you very much okay then on to item
number eight which i think is the last
one on the agenda
strategic planning update October o to
you again okay
so this item six to give members an
update on what these Treaty playing team
has been working on since we leave since
we last provided an update so to give an
overview so the council so that the
strategic planning team has been working
quite heavily on the preparation of what
is now being called the South Wessex
plan so that is being being that is
envisaged to be a development plan
document in the council would seem to
adults that would provide a kind of
strategic overview and would contain
some policies that tackle strategic
cross boundary issues so we have been
working on that with offices from
Buzzard in Brentwood Casa Point South
Bend and therapy councils as part of of
the Association of Southeast explode to
the authorities so that seven six plan
has now been progressing and we are
hopeful that the first stage of
consultation on that may take place
either later this year or probably more
likely early next year clearly that will
have to return to members for a decision
in terms of the new local plan we have
been considering in light of what's
happening with the South Wessex plan on
the on the most effective way of
bringing forward a new local plan it was
originally envisaged in the council's
adopted local development scheme which
is essentially its timetable for
preparing its local plan that we may be
at the consultation on the preferred
option in stage of a new local plan this
autumn evidently that that has not taken
place however I would say that there is
a logical sequence in terms of how the
South Wessex plan and any local plan are
brought forward and therefore in terms
of the in terms of the timetable it does
seem to make sense to go out to
consultation on the
stage of the south physics plan and
before any further stages on on any
local plan therefore subject to members
decision we will be bringing back any a
new revised local development scheme at
a future meeting at the planning policy
subcommittee for members to consider and
subject today to their decision it would
seem to make sense to look to get and
consult on and on the next stage of any
local plan possibly in late spring or
summer of 2020 how a long time obviously
for that South Wessex plan to have gone
out to consultation before it and any
work that's required on that and
obviously that we can provide updates as
part of these regular meetings so in
terms of other matters that the care
that the streeted planning team has been
working on we have been working on the
consultation and the up case this which
they includes involvement that was
considered previously we have been
working on the Essex coast Rams that's
now taken the shape of the SPD that's
that's been considered there is no
update to provide particularly on
neighborhood planning we are still
meeting with the commune and Wallasey
Island neighbourhood planning area they
still have an intention to prepare their
neighborhood plan however it is it is
not going at at a pace and I think they
are reflecting on on their next steps
but they are still quite positive about
bringing forward a neighborhood plan and
then a large amount of the strategic
planning teams work has been on updating
the council's evidence base obviously to
support the development plans that are
being worked on so we have been working
on a Greenbelt study and a landscape
character study both of those are very
important pieces of work when it comes
to considering different locations for
for development in the future those are
being developed jointly with Southend
Borough Council and I'm hopeful that we
may be able to present those to a
meeting at a subcommittee in the next
few months they are both very close to
being finalized and there is also a
considerable amount of work being
developed as part of this asset plan
process so this includes green and blue
infrastructure studies economic land
availability assessment retail studies
and so on and obviously at the other
appropriate time those will also be
presented to to the subcommittee to
consider and then the house of livery
test action planner I think we probably
we probably discussed a lot of what's
taking place on there I suppose the last
thing just to touch on is the councilors
brownfield register and also its cell
from custom field register so we have
been working on an update to the
Brantford register we hope to publish
that as a key decision in the next
couple of months and clearly and that
will go out to members and a sailfin
custom build register we continue to get
people to sign up but it but it there
has been no substantive changes to the
number of people on that but it
continues to provide interest in reading
on the appetite locally for self and
custom building and that's probably all
I have to say on that they said thank
you I know that the anticipated time
spans have been substantially delayed
could you tell me what has delayed 706
joint strategic plan what has gone
this has had an effect on a preferred
option and new local planners as big
demonstrating their report and delayed
the process it's also delayed the
expectations of counselors and of the
public so I think we need to understand
why that is denied but I didn't make a
comment on that vellum and I think
actually there have to be displayed
progressing that plan has has emerged as
a result of political changes that took
place in the May in the May elections
and it was necessary I think for the
objectives in synthesis to meet with the
new leaders and to socialize the the
process of isola and as part of that the
the progression of the of the South
Essex plan which is now being reporting
to a meeting of the leaders on Thursday
morning so this is practical practical
reasons why there has been a bit of
delay in the are you anticipating any
more political Delaney's on changes in
mine above my crystal ball I'm asking if
there's other elections that are going
to affect it because if every year
it says elections every year that affect
the political makeup of this body and
there's delay is to have an effect on us
it is a matter of concern so Chairman I
would hope that once the unit has been
me too
using options and actually a timetable
for the preparation of a pilot that will
that will be embedded and therefore any
political changes will not affect the
progressive coma can we just ask women
when is it anticipated that all the
interested parties will sign up for this
there's a meeting on Thursday morning
more they sign name but the anticipation
is well I can't say yes no no no no okay
is that the plan would see would be
hopeful that the the leaders of the said
mystics authorities in Iceland we've
signed up to the the publication of
issues not detectable for the
preparation they said I think it's
concerning I mean it's an answer yeah
we're now talking about perhaps spring
yeah it's a to my mind that's an
unacceptably delay because it delays in
this cause uncertainty in the community
and they call unrest and I think we
should do everything we can do to make
sure that when we have a time when we
targets and objectives that we Kingston
and I said that something's outside our
control but we should have enough
influence to make sure that it is moving
forward well I think that that message
is has been received I think also you're
talking down about joint proposals
coming forward with South aims that you
hope to have available in the next
couple of months
it's very not prevail then if we need to
bring those to a separate meeting not a
quarterly meeting then we bring them
forward yeah we want to manage we know
these timetables Cristina's highlights
they are critical and we need to keep me
from the mother wises apart from the
concerns it caused to residents are the
alcohol stoves suddenly start causing
concerns to central government and we
have them on our case as well we even we
certainly don't want to go down that
road yes I mean we will we will bring a
new local
skin which like I say I mean is
effectively the timetable that the
council signs up to we will bring a
revised LDS the four members I would
hope before the end of this year and
obviously at that time we're more than
happy to consider what the members
consider and what we know in discussion
we must to be a reasonable an effective
time table from bringing forward those
documents completely there isn't he's
not date them because they are on that
current mom because it is now you know
and now don't to be out of date okay
yeah just concerned here that we have a
timetable it slips we rerun up the
timetable and it's it's just I think
I've already highlights you know being
down here resources yeah that's outside
this committee but we have registered
and how concern that we've got as far as
we're concerned all we can do is
recommend to full council that the
timetables that are proposed are met and
the resources are made available to beat
those timetables one thing I would say
and I'm not saying it's right or wrong
but there are some counselors that I
know that have adopted new local plans
and the the LDS that they've brought to
the examination has been something like
revision nine I'm not saying that's
right but it is it does seem to be part
and parcel unfortunately of introducing
a development plan that there are
unforeseen delays I think I think we
need to be kept aware of these
situations and if if we're made aware of
them then we can highlight them to full
council now whether for council chooses
to act on them is not in the remit of
this group but we can highlight them and
I would suggest the council will take
note of them
and once a word of caution having lots
of officers suddenly doing work doesn't
necessarily mean the timetable will will
be achieved because as I pointed out
there may be very well be other dynamics
in the system that affect the plan I
fully accept that Shawn but we don't
want one of the reasons that it doesn't
progress at the right worry because we
haven't got the resources available if
there are other factors so beard but
let's try and do what we can to
influence and control the bit that we do
control any more any more questions
thank you okay members Ernest there's
anything else the recommendation for
item eight is it is proposed that
subcommittee resolves the strategic
planning work program update October
2019 be noted thank you very much
and nothing closes for meetings thank
you thank you